now let's talk money and marriage before
you're thinking of tying the knot there
are some things to iron out and that's
your money and your partner's money so
here were some advice is professional
Finance expert Russell price with UBS
and his wife and marketing expert Teresa
price thank you guys so much for being
here thank you Jillian and you guys are
married so who better to trust than the
two of you so let's get right to it
obviously getting married is an exciting
time but there are those important
conversations to have before walking
down the aisle so what do you guys
suggest you start with or how to even
begin those conversations
I think first of all you've hit the key
word there having conversations and I
think for us what we did is we really
took a year after marriage to have most
of those conversations and we wanted to
develop coming from two independent
households we both had our ideas of what
Finance meant and we wanted to have
conversations and understand each other
so it's probably best to be obvious
episode but you know some people just
don't even know where to begin with that
so do you guys suggest seeking a
professional you know help to kind of
guide you or what's the first step
you know I think professional guidance
would be great uh for us it was more
about planning towards retirement and
understanding exactly what retirement
meant it was understanding uh it was
understanding what we wanted to do for
our children and that was a lot of
conversations that we could both just
have the conversations and part of it
was emotional uh and and and the
evidence shows a lot of times that men
take over the financial conversation
like I'm doing now
and and but you know so but we when
we're talking about when she was talking
about her when we were talking about her
kids right that's where the emotion came
out we were talking about her life the
lifestyle that went retirement that's
where she was able to project project in
and talk about what she wanted in life
yeah so it's just as important for us
ladies to have a say in everything right
absolutely and when you support yourself
for x amount of years and you have your
own Savings in your own home and things
like that and then you you meet a
partner that you want to share the rest
of your life with I mean those
conversations are very important to have
how are you going to you know combined
finances or not combine finances and so
we did that like Russ said a year after
we got married we started to have those
conversations and come up with a game
plan for our future and for our children
yeah well and when children are involved
that I'm sure adds an extra layer so
it's just important to have those
conversations I've almost made it to a
year of marriage myself so so far
you guys thank you for sharing this it's
a really important conversation to have
and we appreciate you guys being here
thank you thank you all right Kendall
I'll send it